what's up everybody welcome to another
business Q&A as you play League of
Legends answering your entrepreneurial
questions I'm excited to be back as a
Thursday I'm happy looking to start a
new win streak here with my plane
companion J rise under the fresh views
account and I have my usual co-host
Rishi kept TV in the house Rishi how are
we doing feeling the love Evan I'm so
excited to be here as always hi believe
mission happy thursday its stream day
hey out day that's exciting so we're
queuing up we got a game going on but
while we get ready for that tell us
what's in the cup Rishi uh I'm in a
trend right now of coffee in my cup
because I'm believing for a trend in our
win oh here and I evan i'm i'm going to
say I'm feeling a cup of gratitude for
you sir this is why ok I don't know if
you guys meet I don't know if you guys
noticed this about MN but not only is
Evan like believing everybody but like
he truly truly uh is someone that I see
gives and helps without judgment and I
know that you Evan it you helped a lot
of misfits and and you just you just are
really cool I just wanted to honor you
for that and say that's what I'm feeling
today my cup cup of gratitude for your
lack of judgment and and belief in
people alright I appreciate that that
means a lot that means a lot um that's
cool are you getting kind of decent no I
mean it's I just I appreciate it's great
it's great thank you um now there's your
quote I intet we're starting a new
segment of reishi sharing a quote
because i don't have my tea with the
quotes so recently i quote what's up
food I'm related I'm gonna read quote
but it's a good
on the left is the quote by barbara
corcoran you know her she's a
entrepreneur personality on shark tank
she says preparation is grossly
underrated I over prepare for everything
i do try it and let me know what you
think you'll be glad you listened that's
it alright so let's do some Q&A with
some unprepared answers I'm liking it
there we go I like it I like this Rishi
quote of the day I i I'm feeling it see
what's on Rishi's mind alright well J
reyez got rise mid I'm I'm hopefully
gonna get mighty mo jungle and let's get
into some questions who we got what do
we got let's help so much for nice let's
help them let's do it first question is
coming from brian brian brian says kevin
i love the message you send I in college
my business professor and how I wanted
to change the world I said I wanted to
start a company that fun nonprofit he
laughed at me and said it wouldn't work
I'm now testing my process with my book
launch his book is called Coco for Santa
and through october november december i
will be donating a portion of all book
sales to Toys for Tots Midwest shelter
for homeless vets st. Jude's and spinal
muscular atrophy foundation I honestly
think that if a company can partner with
nonprofits that need assistance both the
cherry and the business will thrive I'd
be interested in your thoughts on this
okay all right I love it um I just want
to say absolutely think it's so cool
that you're going into your business
whether as an author or anything else
for the purpose of giving back I think
that's awesome we've talked a lot about
that on the channel
so I think it can work and I think if
that's what you have in your heart you
should make it work no matter what that
being said I just I think that it's so
important to have some kind of a plan in
the beginning before you start anything
sounds like you do have a plan that this
is just general advice I think a lot of
people can get caught up in I want to
give back before they have a plan for
reinvesting back into their business so
that the business can continue to grow
and be what you need it to be it is to
keep getting back so I would just make
sure that you have a good plan for for
every aspect of your business including
reinvesting back into your business and
you know possible cherries I think Evan
even has a video about entrepreneurs who
who gave too soon like they gave too
much too soon in it it was at the
expense of their business so so yeah
absolutely give back I think it can work
but just as they do it responsibly cool
um I was during the start of the very
the very start of the question I'm
thinking that's an awesome college
professor somebody asking how do you
want to change the world like that is
awesome and then he then he laughed at
him like that college professor sucks I
know um I wish my college professor
asked me how I want to change the world
I had boring college professors anyway
side side note our teachers are our
professors you know thinking bigger and
challenging to students and supporting
them as a is important um I mean I love
the cause I think what you need to do is
just find out what how you gonna execute
it like what is so what is your tip what
are your skills your towns that you want
to bring to it so you know for me I like
I believe right I like building people
up i hate untapped potential i want
people to get better and express
themselves and not be trapped where they
are and boxed in where they are
great that's an amazing thing how do i
execute it well it's through the world
of entrepreneurship it's through videos
and live streams and now a book right
through that execution because that's
what I know the world of
entrepreneurship so I love the mission
you want to help nonprofits raise money
okay perfect how are you going to do it
what are you good at is it going to be
by being creative and making great art
through your books and other things and
then selling a portion is going to be
trying to connect businesses with
charities there's a lot of there's a lot
of different ways to be able to do it
and it's going to come from whatever
your unique talents are that you can
really shine with so let's just I love
the idea you just got to figure out what
the business model is going to be that
best shows off you know your skill sets
and talents so you can further your
cause hmm
that's what he got
cool is there kinda like a standard
practice and then for like businesses
that they say will always for charity
have this percentage allotted forgiving
I mean it's at like a standard practice
that people should know or they don't
depend on if I was looking at a standard
practice it would probably be zero you
know like I don't think most businesses
do give back I think they should I think
we have a responsibility to give back to
our community whether it's through you
know donations or percentage of your you
know profits or just in kind you know
like a Toronto dance salsa we gift a lot
of classes will give gift certificates a
lot to charities and you know people who
are trying to raise money for dinners
you know charity auctions that kind of
stuff will either go in and teach teach
a lesson and like entertain the people
or give gift certificates away for
people who are can raise that money in a
silent auction you know going into
schools and helping the kids you know
learn again appreciation of dance and
how it can help them so just giving back
I think should be part of what
businesses do but I don't think it is
foremost I think most people are just so
concerned about surviving then focus on
other you know other causes to be
looking into so no I don't think that
this is standard you know you must give
one percent of your earnings to a
charity but you know doing there is a
cautionary tale to where some people do
it as you said do it too soon and they
don't focus on their business at all and
then you can't you know if you give away
too much of your money too early then
you don't have money to grow and then it
limits your ability to do even more good
right
you need to you need to still be around
and if you're if you're building up to a
you know hundred-person company you'll
be able to give a lot more than you will
right now oh we got first blood pretty
exciting oh sorry guys in game so we're
in game i got Teemo jungle j rise has
rise mid so so far so good so I think
it's I think it's I think it's like I'd
like most of the answers I think it's
both you know I think you need to be
able to do something now to be able to
help out and get back but not go so
crazy on it that it limits your ability
to do things with your business that
being said don't be only business minded
that you know you don't focus at all
about giving back and helping your
community and mentoring helping the
people around you doesn't have to take a
lot of money doesn't have to take a lot
of time and I think there's a model here
for Brian where if you want to go into
approach businesses and and help them
get back and give them ideas and how
they can contribute I get Brian came up
to me and said hey can you can you gift
us certificates we want to do a gift
certificate program can you give us some
gift certificates that we can then use
for private auctions for charities for
their fundraising galas and all that
stuff it'd be an easy yes and you can go
and do that too tons of different
businesses and you know now all these
charities that need items for their
auctions you know they have something
because of Brian's hard work but it
means you have to go out and talk to
businesses and you know get to know
entrepreneurs and go networking and get
on social media and like that can work
all of these things can work it's just
is it what you want to do is that what
you're excited about so that's that's
what I meant by you have to find the
thing that you can be really good at so
that when you start executing it's
something that brings you a lot of joy
as well as furthers your mission
okay so look for like you guys r 1 and 0
right now don't you go do we do
something with us let's do some who's in
the chat let's do some recognition oh we
didn't do that yeah super fun actually
in the chest blowing up as usual we've
got fries online we've got day no in the
house we've got de mas de mosta dome at
the mine in the house it's not supposed
to be said that way that's my own thing
say no new and house in the house who
Zeno nuin house is in the house yeah
that's funny because I've never actually
tried to pronounce the last part of his
or his last name so good for you for
doing that well this is video and I've
done better though that wasn't my dress
but there's a video on it oh I thought
it was a video but I thought it was just
the first name it did you do the last
thing too oh the whole point of it was
for the last name oh wow yeah let's
check out that video hey I'm sorry hey
you know okay and then off the source is
back I off the source great to see you
and I think that's it for today um yeah
let's do it so let's go to the next
question next question is coming from
Regina Regina says greetings Evan my
name is Regina first time I thank you
for giving back giving back and
inspiring others every day I think
you're awesome I wanted to know if you
could share a few ideas or websites that
could be helpful to me in the creation
process of developing a business plan
I'm stuck because I'm not sure how to go
about the development of my business
plan I'm not even sure how to get
started I would really appreciate help
that would aid in the process of
developing and outline to a business
plan that I could follow
oh I almost want to tell you that I'm on
my way to invest in myself by buying
your new book thank you for all the work
that you are doing that is truly making
a huge impact in people's life on a
daily basis and I pray that god bless
everything that you touch sincerely
Regina okay so awesome love that you
just bought the book super cool for
those of you who do by the book that's
just number one a great choice but
number two you get a shout out to look
up for your shoutout when you purchase
and also you know the business plan
question I think is a common question
for people want to get started I think
what I think what gets complicated for
people is that they think they have to
have this very very perfect plan before
they get started but at a very basic
level of business plan is just a guide
and a roadmap that kind of outlines your
goals in details how you're going to
meet those goals um and I think the
place to start would be really
identifying what business you're in
because I think that will also influence
a little bit how you then plan for
example are you going to be a storefront
business are you going to be online are
you going to be a service-based business
are you going to be a product based
business so I think the more you can
identify what business you are in it
will be easier to then find that
business plan model after and I remember
just too I remember asking you this
question myself as and when I was
starting on youtube I was like what's
the business plan you know um yeah
that's not why I got into YouTube but
then
I met you shortly thereafter and I was
so excited about all this information I
was like okay let's let's implement this
and your answer to your response to me
was hey throw that throw that out for
right now and just focus on putting more
love into your YouTube channel so it's
not that a plan isn't important but I
think the more that you can just really
identify where your business is going to
be it will and for what your business is
going to be it can more easily answer
all of the practical how-to step yeah
cool I think you need to figure out what
you need the business plan for so is it
just for yourself to have kind of a
guide for what you're going to do or is
it for an investor or for you know some
other purposes as well because if you're
making a plan to try to get investment
it's different than if you're just going
to make it for yourself I agree with
reaching that i would i would really
think strongly of just not being so
hamstrung by having the perfect point
that you don't do anything that you
don't get started at all i think that's
for people who love the plan and for you
know the perfectionist is definitely a
common thing that people struggle with
i'm not going to do anything until it's
perfect and you know the thing is it
never is perfect and this is this is one
of the things that cost me a lot early
in my career as I might own on another
video okay with a kill we're doing wow
man Jay and I are teaming up we're
getting kills this is looking good so
far this game um yeah I lost out on a 42
million dollar deal because I was no
trying to make the perfect plane and I
lost out on a big opportunity so that
that's the danger the thing to realize
what the business plan is that it
changes as soon as you as soon as you
get out there on the market so did you
certain times when you're so much is
going to change so
it doesn't mean don't plan because you
need to have a plan and it's great to
have a general sense of what you're
going to do how you're going to market
your business what's so unique and
special about you you know what you
stand for all of those things are really
important but not being so hamstrung by
just trying to have the perfect plan
that you don't do anything I think
that's important that being said like
resources places how do you go find a
good business plan it's funny when you
look at business plans how much variety
there is there are some comment sections
and you could just go look at you know a
bank website and you'll see you know
most most of the bank websites have
business plan template to you can you
can learn from but even as part of the
thinking part of the bonuses that we
have in the for the book which if you
ordered you'll you'll see some bonuses
there some of some of the company's
original business plans you know the New
Yorkers first business plan how you know
it's like three pages right you have it
in your pony pig yeah there's a couple
of them's a couple there's a couple
business plan examples in the bonuses
that are that are worth checking out
yeah but it's for a general template you
can go to any any bank website and
they'll have examples for you to follow
none of those are should be taking that
like this is the only way to do it
they're all just general guidelines
really what you want to feel like is you
have applying the follow it gives you
the confidence that what you're doing is
you know gonna work that's it so i would
i would go check out the bank websites
but also not get to cut up and it having
to be perfect
yeah I mean I'm not the expert in the
business department like you Evan but I
think about like teaching a costume of
kids which I do have experience with and
so you can bland all you want to to do
that well and manage the classroom and
teach little but gonna require you
getting in the classroom and actually
just getting your hands dirty before you
really kind of know what you're doing
we've got to execute anniversary we've
got some people in the channel so saying
optiv source book says that tiny Robin
says not to make a business plan but if
business quote math and but yeah
everybody looks like everybody everybody
in different ways that they like to
approach this I think we all just be
defined it works for us and and also
model people that you really respect you
know there's a kind of business that you
really respect that you're going to do
you know models model the Masters there
all right just making sure we're caught
up on the chat all right all right I
think that's it so next question comes
from Andre I'm Justin hi Evan hi Evan
hope you're doing great dude love the
shows on YouTube you're doing a great
job I followed your channel religiously
ahaha Evan what do you know about growth
hacking if I tell you that I could
possibly recommend you the realest death
in GH ATM that has given crazy amounts
of value around the world would you
consider it grow attacking is a new
trend in the stout up space great skill
set for your audience to know it's the
street smarts mentality baby
in all honesty thank you for your great
work is he trying to pay I don't
understand the question there did I miss
something I feel like I no no I I feel
like if they didn't want to be too quick
to say that but I think it sounds fishy
and yeah okay yeah so he's trying to
pitch me on on being a growth hacker for
me it looks like it I don't know what GH
ATM is so I don't know what it is either
oh yeah all right well I well I uh but
it looks like if it was i was getting
this email I would feel like I'm being
pitched to and I personally like much
prefer getting personally personal
emails but that's just me okay cool so
you know growth hacking definitely
growth hack is basically having somebody
to come in and help you build your
community build the audience get your
social campaigns going get get a
community of you know of an audience for
you to test out your products and
services with it it's just it's it's the
new street marketing but online that's
what this growth hacking and it's a it's
it's important a lot of entrepreneurs
using it you should it's cheap marketing
compared to traditional methods I would
I appreciate I love the bravado that
he's bringing off I love the energy in
the excitement I would I would look at
the execution you know so you're a fan I
love it thank you for all the love and
support I'm sitting here listen to the
message and i'm confused you know rishi
was reading it often is confused neither
of us know what this whatever that name
was GMH whatever
cash machine or voyeur what it was you
know we don't know what that is and so
part of being a good growth hacker right
is communicating the message that makes
sense so the ambition and drive and I
love all that now we got to work on you
know communicating the message that
resonates with people and if you can do
that you can find those talents man then
you'll do well yeah all right thanks
Evan next question is coming from cuba
cuba is thing hey bro love your videos
really inspirational could you do a
video on it's never too late i feel like
i'm too old to go forth and pursue my
dream and was so i would love so if you
could make a video on that already cuba
thank you for the question and i think
this is a absolutely important topic so
many people feel this way and you'd be
surprised that it's not just people in
midlife who feel this way you can hear
this concern even from teenagers like
it's too is too late for me to try which
is kind of a scary thought that
teenagers still that way but i
absolutely yes it's never too late and
that is talked about a lot on Evan
channel one video that I love is we
talked earlier at the top of the show
that this today thursday is hangout day
and i'm a big fan of hang out with evan
and s kelly CEO of stage Stephen Kelly
and they did a interview collab on the
very topic it's called is it too late
for you to be a success and so if you
search the channel for that
again is it too late for you to be a
success at the name of that video and I
mean it's just so many examples of
amazing entrepreneurs who found success
well past you know 40s into midlife and
beyond so it's not too late the big
fight we are in a big fight guys we're
in a big fight what's gonna happen we're
gonna do damage yeah okay good that was
that was on the stressful side but we
made it through and I'm pretty happy
about it um yeah I mean I I chalked that
up wonder am I too am I to anything
right is it in my tool when you young am
I to you know whatever it is that that's
a great video I forgot about that so
thank you for bringing that back up
putting it on the map again Rishi the
two examples that I usually use when i'm
looking at the older entrepreneurs or
give ray kroc who didn't get started
till he was in his 50s who built
McDonald's mm-hmm and he you know had
diabetes and all of these ailments and
you know everybody was said like your
your life is on the decline this is you
know this that's it man is the end of
the road just start thinking about
retirement and then he went on to build
McDonald's um Colonel Sanders who built
KFC was in his 60s guy is pretty old he
was in a 60s right so like when at a
time when most people are are thinking
about retirement here here's this guy
off doing some brand new venture right
it's just it's just a just a mindset
whoa I'm getting destroyed holy cow I
got I got attacked by four people good
time well that's okay we're gonna we're
gonna win we're doing
on this game um yeah so idea i would
start to look at examples of people who
have done it so i can see how if you
look at a UH you know Mark Zuckerberg
and you say wow look at him like they
really belong to the young entrepreneur
I can't do anything I'm too old but you
just give up on my dream um ton of
people who started who are starting now
who are older than you who are having
tons of success and so to start putting
those people on your radar start
surround yourself with that so you have
that belief that i can do it too I think
will be important if you really want to
do it like and this is a lesson to pass
on to I don't know if I don't know if he
has kids or not if she was it again
wasn't it uh this is diba diba okay so i
don't know people has kids but she's a
keen with AK Kiba teba key at KI be a
boy she bad Kiba okay so like I don't
know if kippah has kids but it is that
the message that you want to pass on mmm
that living and believe that you know
the world tells you that you can't do it
so you're not gonna do it mm-hmm right
and if anything that's an inspiration
you could be an inspiration to everyone
around you and say look look what I did
a just age is it gonna hold me down yeah
yeah and it's just an a it's just an
example of a limiting belief and you'll
have tons of them we all will have them
so break it this one will help break
others and is important
so it's not too late yeah it's not too
late and I have to always I I actually
officially got this book in the mail and
super excited the book I always plug for
this particular question is it's never
too late to begin again by Julia camera
now it's not a book for necessarily
specifically entrepreneurs but it's for
anyone who's been midlife that feels or
really anyone creative person that feels
like it's too late and it addresses I
think some really practical ways to take
steps toward what you're doing I don't I
just I'm excited to read that book even
though I'm not midlife yet but I'm
excited to read that book actually wait
and I am in life yet my nose midlife
start your millennial how do I not know
or miss lifer like there's something
really wrong with that there's lots of
love there's lots of love hurry she
thanks for lack of judgment Evan
appreciate you okay okay next question
is coming from Patrick that's right yeah
Patrick says hey Evan I really like your
content and the fact that you inspire
people my name is Patrick I'm from
Croatia I would like that you would be
my mentor I don't have any experience in
business but i have but i will learn it
from you but i would like to learn it
from you if you want to help me I would
be very grateful talk to you soon I hope
alright so one thing that I don't think
people realize so they can we get this
question a lot is that you know you re
are being mentored you know you found
the channel and making more videos than
probably any other YouTube channel a day
it's just giving away
free value it's just there for you and
the only thing stopping you from being
mentored by not doing not taking action
on what you're learning on the channel
um I get that we all want that like
one-on-one and that is has its place and
it's super important absolutely uh but
don't let the fact that you don't have
that stop you from being mentored
because you know Ivan says all the time
you get mentored by this video's that he
has on his own channel so um yeah I'm
all kind of stuff there than you know
you might have some more to add there to
that yeah we've talked a lot about
mentorship before on the channel um
definitely a definitely super important
but realizing that yes you are one
already being mentored you know watching
these videos you're being mentored and
still trying to surround yourself with
more of that content whoever it is that
you know inspires you motivate to makes
you excited do it on the other hand if
you're trying to get like in person
stuff then the frustrating thing is you
know nobody's going to come and just say
yeah I'm going to be your mentor because
it again implies a longer term
relationship and so just starting off
with a question like I'm frustrated
because I don't I would love to have
contacts so I can help you with
something if you want to be mentored by
somebody then then ask a specific one
question that you need help with and
then go and do something about it we're
just saying I want to be mentored
doesn't give anybody enough context that
actually give you some help and so I'm
sitting here playing and I'm frustrated
because I want to help and I don't have
the contacts to be able to do it because
it didn't get asked a question around it
I'm sure so hopefully that's a
lesson for next time in general like
even not forget about just business
mentorship any kind of mentorship you
know you want to go in and ask in a
specific question make it easy for
somebody to say yes oh we are we
fighting it what's happening here we're
fighting we're fighting no not fighting
them let's make it easy date before you
get married that's it that's what I got
good luck good luck and then I think to
just for those who are listening and who
might be watching our regular basis and
emailing in just a reminder that you
know whether it's just for this Q&A or
for anything like the more you can ask a
question with a clear topic and how you
want to get help you know I just wanted
to say that maybe to help anyone else
who writes in going forward we get a lot
of questions that don't have a lot of
detail they're very general and you
often then don't know how to really give
the most value which I know you are all
about wanting to give value so yeah so
if you're writing in a question try to
be as concise like I'm not saying like
you have to go into detail where you
have like pages of questions but concise
into the point of how you specifically
need help that will help us I think give
you what you're actually looking for
topically so and I'm that is that okay
for me to say that second yeah I think
in general like in life clarity is a
important thing clear down what you want
clarity on what you need help with
clarity clarity's 30 can be very
powerful ally
hmm well my team is getting destroyed so
I think we need to back out of this
fight see if I can save J reyez jerez is
save so good all right well we're going
to win but we have one more push so
let's do another question one more
question a thing let's do it okay that's
good next question is coming from
tanveer and tundra says hi Evan I'm ton
beer from Bangladesh I'm also from a
lower a lower-middle-class family yeah
lower middle class like emphasizing
lower anyways I watched your vid one of
your videos where you sit to believe in
yourself I think it's mainly for the
people who are willing to start a
business or something similar to that
but in my case I'm just a year 12
student who wants to study abroad for
his better future but I don't have
enough money for that and neither my
family supports please tell me how I can
overcome this I'm requesting you to not
ignore this on i will appreciate with
all my love to get your assistance
tanveer so yeah tanger cool super cool
thanks for writing a lot of people come
to the channel not just because they're
you know entrepreneurs we see all the
time people who are just there because
of the belief and that's really what
it's all about and transcends
entrepreneurship so cool question and
you want to study abroad but you feel
like you don't have the money or the
support I think that kind of comes down
to what you it really does come down to
believe you know again you probably
found the channel because that's
something that you yourself are meeting
when you don't have support it's really
hard to sometimes find that inner sense
of belief in yourself
so I just wanted to encourage you that
the lack of money or lack of support
really even though it seems like it it's
a huge setback you can overcome that and
I think that it just it comes with you
starting to practice some
resourcefulness researching ways to find
funds or grants or scholarships or study
it comes from asking maybe if your
family doesn't support you may be there
are people around you and you're in your
school or that can there always will be
away if you really really believe that
and I think that's kind of that's where
it starts is like believing that you can
figure it out regardless of obstacles
that are in front of you yeah I love it
well we won the game I had a I got my s
minus on the team i got i went 3 kills
one death and five assists jeyaraj was
41 and eight so we have a new win streak
starting up yeah which I'm excited by
bre she's talking it up um yes I agree
you know the channel is not just for
entrepreneurs it initially was my
intention to help entrepreneurs because
that's who I can help the best but the
message of believe is for everybody
everybody has to believe in themselves
and what they can do and what they're
all about in the you know the impact
that they can have if you don't believe
that then you're you're going to
continue being where you are so I a lot
of the content is geared towards
entrepreneurs to again just because I
have more knowledge there than anything
else but if I'm in this situation i'm
looking at two things at the core is
really how badly do you want it and what
are you willing to do to get it so you
know on the one hand if if this foreign
education is the thing that you must
have in your life that you know you will
not be successful less you
that education some of the country then
one work really really hard right now to
raise money to go and do it and to just
find a way to go there get to that
country make it work you know there's
people who land in countries all the
time with a lot less than what you have
and figure out their path but that's a
painful and uncertain in scary thing to
do so you may not want it badly enough
to do that and to maybe it's not all
that important like so many people have
had tremendous success without having to
go to a foreign university that is not
the be all and end all of you you could
learn a lot I think you can learn a lot
more this is bold you can learn a lot
more by watching my channel then you
could add a typical university education
and you I said it I said it um hey
you're right you can't like any specific
knowledge you can find online and it's
free you just got to do the work to
listen apply it you can do the work so
that's not what's holding you back the
school is not what's holding you back
and I would actually much rather you
pull that limiting mindset that you have
to go to that University be successful
then you you know going to start a
business to try to raise money for that
or you know smuggle your way into that
country or whatever it is because you
can have massive success without going
to that school and until you believe
that then you won't so mm-hmm there's
some more belief for you
mm-hmm that's what I got I'm excited so
much opportunity ahead mm-hmm go well we
won our game thank you guys for all the
love I see the chat has having some good
discussion there the live chat Rishi how
do we want to I want to end their day
what's our message well we need to
decide are we just going to stay
consistent with our obeying message are
we ending with the difference that's a
lot of messages I like having an end
like I like how you think about what's
happened today and then you end with our
final reminder for everybody yeah cool
I'm pull together the different themes
that we've discussed and then you wrap
it up in this little Rishi nugget for us
to sit on you know for the rest of the
day oh yes and I'm going to try to do a
message with clarity being clear and
concise because that's what helps
everybody so the message for today is
you don't need a business plan you don't
need support of the people you hope you
have support from you don't need the
money you don't need the approval of
your professor who tells you that you
can't do what it is that you said you
were going to do you just need your
belief I like it believe that's all you
need yeah believe is all you need do do
do it's true all right we're in a good
mood well thank you guys so much for
watching this some more interviews and
things happen on the channels today five
live streams I think still coming up but
if this is the last time I see you hope
you have an amazing day I believe in you
guys I hope you believe in yourselves
and whatever your one word is much love
we'll see you soon